[Applaudissements]
son potentiel semble ne pas avoir de
limites
mélanie de jésus dos santos a encore
éclaboussé son public de sa grâce mais
par asymétrique n'ont plus de secret
pour elle ma place à des papilles
positif parce que j'ai réussi
le principal donc les bars il ya eu des
petites erreurs
aujourd'hui en poutre je suis quand même
satisfaite parce que je reste déçu
c'était le plus important mais bilan
général c'est bien aussi
j'ai fait mon travail malgré une petite
contre performance sur la poutre la
martiniquaise avait à coeur de rectifier
le tir après sa performance de 2018 sur
les barres asymétriques
mélanie a déterminé 8e l'an passé mais
aujourd'hui est déjà tournée vers demain
c'est quand même une compétition qui est
assez proche des mondes donc il ya
vraiment des filles qui viennent pour se
préparer il n'y a pas tout le monde de
toutes les nations rendez vous donc pour
les championnats du monde en octobre
prochain à stuttgart
la petite mélanie de jésus dos santos
sera comme un poisson dans l'eau
parmi les géantes de la discipline
[Musique]